Wir stecken mitten in einer globalen Gesundheitskrise
- und zwar bedingt durch die Vielzahl an Problemkeimen:
Bakterien also, die resistent sind gegen Antibiotika.
Besorgniserregend ist, dass auch die Suche
nach neuen Antibiotika alles andere als einfach
ist.
Deswegen suchen Forschungsteams weltweit fieberhaft
nach Alternativen.
Große Hoffnung setzten Experten und Expertinnen
in eiskalte “Bakterienfresser”.
Diese sogenannten “Phagen” sind darauf
programmiert, Bakterien zu töten - und das
mit einer zerstörerischen Kraft.
In Laborversuchen kommen die Bakterienfresser
sogar gegen multiresistente Keime an.
Könnten Phagen also die Menschheit tatsächlich
vor dem Schlimmsten bewahren?
Clixoom Science & Fiction, hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Dieser Themenvorschlag kam übrigens dutzendweise
über WhatsApp, da habt ihr übrigens null
Risiko ein Video zu verpassen.
Ihr bekommt nämlich immer eine Nachricht
und ihr könnt super Themen vorschlagen.
Der Link ist in der Videobeschreibung und
kommt nochmal am Ende des Videos.
Wir haben erst vor Kurzem bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction über die Killerkeime berichtet,
die sich mittlerweile auf der ganzen Welt
breit gemacht haben.
Und das auch in den entlegensten Winkeln dieser
Erde; beispielsweise im eigentlich unberührten
Arktis-Boden.
Es scheint also so, dass wir Menschen den
Superkeimen schutzlos ausgeliefert sind und
die Waffen der Medizin immer stumpfer werden:
Studien zufolge sterben schon jetzt jährlich
weltweit 700.000 Menschen an Infektionen durch
medikamenten-resistente Keime.
Bis 2050 könnte diese Zahl auf zehn Millionen
Opfer steigen.
Das sagen zumindest Hochrechnungen einer britischen
Forschungsgruppe voraus.
Im Klartext hieße das dann: Mehr Tote durch
resistente Erreger als durch Krebserkrankungen.
Das kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen,
aber es gibt immer wieder Menschen, die an
bakteriellen Infektionen sterben.
Und zwar unter den Augen von Ärzten, die
verzweifelt ein Antibiotikum nach dem anderen
verabreichen - und das ohne Erfolg!
Die Vereinten Nationen hatten die multiresistenten
Keime schon 2016 als die “größte und dringendste
Gefahr” überhaupt bezeichnet.
Und so forschen Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
weltweit mit Hochdruck daran, neue Waffen
gegen Superkeimen zu entwickeln, um noch das
Schlimmste abzuwenden.
Bakterienfresser, sogenannte Phagen, könnten
manchen Fachleuten zufolge, vielleicht die
letzte Hoffnung zu sein.
Im biologischen Sinne kann man sie als Viren
bezeichnen, die es allerdings einzig und allein
auf Bakterien abgesehen haben und diese angreifen
und auflösen - in der Fachsprache spricht
man von “lysieren”.
Phagen sind eigentlich überall - es gibt
Schätzungen, nach denen sie zehnmal häufiger
sind als Bakterien.
Und auch in unserem Körper sind ständig
Phagen zu finden, die wir beispielsweise über
Wasser und Essen aufnehmen.
Spannend dabei ist, dass Phagen wirklich alles
andere als das NEUE Wundermittel sind.
Die Bakterienfresser wurden nämlich schon
100 Jahren entdeckt.
Die Wirte der Phagen sind Bakterien und so
können sich Phagen tatsächlich auch lediglich
in Bakterienzellen vermehren und eben nicht
alleine.
Ein Phage besteht einzig und allein aus seiner
DNA, also seiner Erbsubstanz, die sich in
einer Proteinhülle befindet.
Insgesamt sind Phagen deutlich kleiner als
Bakterienzellen.
Das Besondere an diesen Bakterienfressern
ist, dass sie spezifisch sind.
Das bedeutet, dass ein Phage nur Bakterien
mit entsprechender Zelloberfläche angreifen
kann.
Das passiert nach dem sogenannten “Schlüssel-Schloss-Prinzip”.
Ein wesentlicher Pluspunkt - ganz im Gegenteil
zu Antibiotika, die zwar spezifisch gegen
bestimmte Bakterien sein können, aber eben
nicht spezifisch gegen eine bestimmte Bakterienart
oder Bakterienstämme.
Und der “Überfall” eines Phagen auf ein
Bakterium ist wirklich nicht ohne: Der Phage
schießt nämlich eiskalt sein Erbmaterial
in das Bakterium.
Dieses wird dadurch gezwungen, neue Generationen
an Phagen herzustellen.
Bis die Bakterienzelle dann voll ist mit jungen
Phagen und letztendlich platzt.
Die vielen neuen Phagen ziehen dann ebenfalls
los, um weitere Bakterienzellen anzufallen.
Ähnlich wie bei einem Antibiotikum kann es
passieren, dass einzelne Bakterienzellen eine
Resistenz gegen den spezifischen Phagen entwickeln.
Doch das lassen sich die Phagen nicht gefallen
und entwickeln ebenfalls sogenannte “Mutationen”.
Diese versetzen sie dann in die Lage, auch
die eigentlich resistenten Bakterien anzugreifen.
Wenn somit alle Ziel-Bakterien abgetötet
sind, zerfällt der Phage selbst in seine
Bestandteile, da es ihm an Nahrung fehlt.
Der menschliche Organismus ist in der Lage,
die Reste der Bakterienfresser zu verstoffwechseln.
Und das Problem ist gelöst.
Und es gibt einen weiteren enormen Vorteil
der Bakterienfresser im Vergleich zu Antibiotika:
Denn es gibt wohl nur wenige Nebenwirkungen
wie etwa Allergien.
Doch zu 100 Prozent sicher sind die Phagen
wohl auch nicht.
Denn Studien konnten zeigen, dass sie ungeahnte
Fähigkeiten haben, die uns langfristig gesehen
auch schaden könnten.
Offensichtlich sind sie wohl in der Lage,
unter gewissen Umständen Resistenzen auf
Bakterien zu übertragen.
Dabei dienen sie als eine Art Informations-Vehikel,
das genetische Vorlagen eines Bakteriums in
die neu befallenen Bakterien mit einbringt.
Diese waren dann im Experiment unempfindlich
gegen antibiotische Wirkstoffe.
Fatal!
Die Phagen hatten die Bakterien also nicht
zerstört, sondern im Gegenteil: Sie hatten
sie sogar noch gefährlicher werden lassen!
Genanalysen könnten dieses Risiko allerdings
senken.
Zusammengefasst könnten die meisten ihrer
Eigenschaften die Phagen dennoch zu einer
wirklich guten Alternative zu Antibiotika
machen.
Weltweit laufen dazu viele Experimente.
In einigen konnten die Bakterienfresser zeigen,
dass sie sogar gegen multiresistente Bakterien
ankommen.
Im Übrigen gilt: Eine Phagen- und Antibiotikum-Therapie
schließen sich nicht grundsätzlich aus,
sondern können auch nebeneinander angewendet
werden.
Super daran ist einfach, dass Phagen unbegrenzt
zur Verfügung stehen - und zwar in natürlichen
Systemen.
Wegen der Spezifität, die ich eben schon
angesprochen hatte, ist es dann notwendig,
die geeigneten Phagen gegen den bestimmten
Krankheitserreger zu finden.
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler nehmen
dafür beispielsweise Proben aus Klärwasser.
Dort gibt es besonders viele Phagen - Schätzungen
zufolge bis zu 100 Millionen verschiedene
Arten in nur einem Milliliter.
Erfolgversprechend sind Phagen bei der Behandlung
von bakteriellen Infektionen - spannend nicht
nur für chronisch Lungenkranke, Brandverletzte,
sondern auch für Diabetiker, die Probleme
mit offenen Wunden haben.
Doch trotz der vielversprechenden Eigenschaften
der Phagen, werden sie in Deutschland bzw.
in Westeuropa und der USA bisher nicht als
Therapiemittel eingesetzt.
Ganz anders als in Georgien, wo dieser Behandlungsansatz
schon lange etabliert ist.
Doch bisher gibt es bei uns trotz intensiver
Forschungsbemühungen keine Studien, die die
Sicherheit und Wirksamkeit der Phagen sicher
beweisen können. 2017 hat das Bundesforschungsministerium
immerhin die ersten klinischen Studien mit
Bakteriophagen in Deutschland genehmigt.
Doch es gibt zudem auch bürokratische Hürden.
Denn rechtlich ist hier noch viel zu tun,
damit Phagen innerhalb der EU zugelassen werden
könnten: Handelt es sich um Medikamente,
Impfstoffe oder ist es gar eine komplett neue
Klasse an medizinischen Produkten!?
Muss vielleicht sogar jede einzelne Phagenmedikament,
das zusammengemischt wird, zugelassen werden
oder ist eine generelle Zulassung möglich?
Bis in Deutschland offiziell Phagenmittel
eingesetzt werden dürfen, brauchen wir wohl
noch etwas Geduld.
Dabei sollten sich die Behörden allerdings
etwas sputen.
Denn das Resistenzproblem wird immer größer
werden.
Doch erst wenn die Bürokratie geklärt ist,
könnten die Phagen im Kampf gegen Superkeime
mitmischen.
Und es sind nicht wenige Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler, die sich ganz sicher
sind, dass Phagen uns aus der “globalen
Krise “ retten könnten.
Resistente Bakterien bedrohen die Menscheit.
Für dieses Video mit noch mehr Infos hier
drauf klicken.
Und hier geht es zur WhatsApp-Community.
Anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!